foreign
it's important to study heredity because
it allows us to understand basic core
parts of biology
why do organisms look like their parents
How do organisms adapt to their
environment in addition to being
interesting heredity has been important
for humans throughout our entire
Evolution we've used aspects of heredity
without understanding them to make
better crops we've made better apples
we've made corn we've made wheat
recently we have used techniques and
genetics to make rice resistant to
Drought therefore increasing the
opportunities for us to prevent food
shortages so throughout human
development we have used the tools that
are preventity to make our lives better
heredity is the process by which parents
whether they be humans or peas pass on
their genetic information to their
offspring and it this really answers the
question about why Offspring look like
their parents so for example if your
parents have blue eyes you tend to have
blue eyes as well
a lot of our understanding of genetics
at least the our understanding of modern
genetics comes from the work in the
1860s of a monk called Gregor Mendel
Gregor Mendel working in his garden
using pea plants discovered a lot of the
rules that govern The Inheritance and
our understanding of how genes are
passed passed on from one generation to
another but Mendel discovered using
simple organisms and simple traits such
as P color is that parents pass on a
single copy of a gene to their offspring
so that an offspring has two copies of a
gene one from each parent
genes are discrete units of information
genes often make proteins and proteins
are the basic some of the basic blocks
in the cell we now know that these genes
are made up of DNA
we also Now understand is that that
within a cell genes are organized into
very large DNA molecules called
chromosomes each chromosome containing
thousands of genes
individuals get one chromosome and one
copy of every Gene from one parent and a
second copy of their chromosomes and
their Gene from their other parent so
each
person has two copies of each gene these
two copies are called alleles
these alleles may not be identical so
that the one from the father and the one
from the mother may not be exactly the
same copies of this of the gene in
Mendel's Garden he discovered that pea
plants have different colors of peas
this trait a pea color was due to
different alleles of a single Gene so
there was one allele for a yellow p and
one allele for a green Peak so that an
organism could have two copies of the
yellow allele two copies of the green
allele or one copy of the green allele
and one copy of the yellow allele if the
P received two of the yellow alleles the
P was yellow if the P received one
allele that was yellow and one allele
that was green the P was still yellow
meaning that yellow is dominant and
green is recessive the P was only green
if it received two copies of the green
allele one from each parent
this combination of the genes and the
alleles is the genotype of the P the
phenotype is the observed trait in this
case the color of the Pea yellow or
green
mendelian traits are simple traits that
are governed by a single Gene there are
very few examples of these in humans in
Plants Mendel originally discovered that
traits such as the color of a pea is
determined by a single Gene and this so
therefore P color is a mendelian trait a
multifactorial trait is a trait that is
controlled by many different forms of
many different genes plus environmental
influences
in humans things such as height certain
inherited cancers
are multifactorial